foreign
over 1 million people lose their lives
in automobile accidents each year
researchers are trying to reduce
accidents and save lives by developing
technologies that assist people with
driving cars and will eventually allow
cars to drive themselves
self-driving cars may sound like science
fiction but experimentation with
automated Driving Systems began back in
the 1920s
beginning with remote controlled Phantom
Autos from 100 years ago automated
Driving Systems today are computer
controlled and they work by creating a
map of their surroundings using sensors
driverless cars have an exciting
potential to revolutionize the way we
travel though there is still a long road
ahead the Society of Automotive
Engineers has a six level classification
system to define the different levels of
driving automation along a spectrum
the classification ranges from Level
zero or no automation to level 5 or
complete automation
the higher the level the less input is
required from the human driver to
operate the car
at the moment the highest automation
level available for Consumer purchase is
somewhere between levels 2 and 3 which
means that today's semi-autonomous cars
can steer accelerate and or decelerate
on their own but the driver must
intervene if certain conditions make it
so that the car can't interpret its
surroundings
automobile and tech companies are
experimenting with higher levels of
automation but completely automated cars
will likely not be available for another
few decades
one important technology that allows
today's semi-autonomous vehicles to see
is lidar short for light detection and
ranging lidar sensors determine
distances between the car and
surrounding objects like other cars
pedestrians bicyclists and even curbs by
sending out pulses of light and
measuring how long it takes for the
light to reflect back to the sensor
but lidar can only sense objects that
are relatively close to the car and
sometimes its measurements are not
accurate enough to distinguish one
object from another
and when multiple self-driving cars are
on the same road their lidar signals can
interfere
cameras are another critical technology
that help Vehicles interpret the road
they visually detect objects like
traffic lights street signs and Road
markings other Technologies such as GPS
radar and vehicle-to-vehicle
communication allow cars to understand
the precise position on the road
relative to nearby objects
the power of driverless cars lies in
their dependence on multiple sensors
each one provides specialized
information on what's happening on the
road and they support each other in case
one fails
once the car's sensors collect all this
information computers analyze it and
decide how the car should drive in
response to its surroundings
processing such a large amount of data
is a challenge and there's no way to
program a computer to respond to every
possible signal it might receive
for that reason researchers are
experimenting with machine learning
which trains a car's computer on large
amounts of sample data so that it can
eventually make decisions on data it has
never seen despite their supply of
high-tech sensors self-driving cars can
fall short for instance automated
Driving Systems don't function as well
when there is heavy precipitation when
Lane divisions are not clearly painted
or when litter clutters the road since
their sensors can get confused in
addition imagine a pedestrian crossing
the street a driver sees The Pedestrian
makes eye contact and waves them on
signaling that the driver will stop
their car so The Pedestrian can cross
safely but autonomous vehicles cannot
make eye contact with human beings or
communicate in such subtle ways there
are also questions of Ethics regarding
driverless cars who is responsible when
an autonomous vehicle gets into a car
accident with no driver to blame is it
the fault of the car manufacturer the
people who develop the computer programs
or the local authorities responsible for
regulations Road design and maintenance
another ethical dilemma is concern for
driver privacy for example some of
today's semi-autonomous vehicles have
driver assist Technologies such as eye
trackers which monitor a driver's
attention using a camera that detects
head position eye position and eyelid
movement in some semi-autonomous
Vehicles if the system determines that
the driver is distracted or asleep the
car will alert the driver or if
necessary slow itself to a stop
while there are many challenges to
overcome autonomous vehicles offer a
promising future
unlike humans they can't become tired or
inebriated car travel could become more
accessible if it is easier for people
with physical disabilities to operate a
driverless vehicle
on the other hand the financial
accessibility of driverless cars is
variable currently cars with automated
Driving Systems range in price from 15
to 100 000 US dollars
self-driving cars could also make roads
safer and more efficient to travel on
once their sensor technology has
advanced to the point where they can
interpret and respond to a variety of
road conditions better than human
drivers this increased efficiency
combined with cars being powered by
electricity means self-driving cars
could play a major role in reducing the
environmental impact of the
transportation sector
although we are still at least a few
decades away from commercially available
fully autonomous vehicles that were
first dreamed of a century ago there's
no doubt that we've begun Paving the way
towards a driverless future
[Music]